sharing with the audience your
background and then let's get into your
ideas of why you think we shouldn't be
concerned with the population growing
the way that it is or maybe we should be
so I I think that it all started with
growing up in the Communist so if you
can get closer absolutely so growing up
on the communism then coming to the
capitalist West and realizing that uh
um you know different regimes and
different countries have different sets
of political and economic arrangements
and so I was always interested in what
makes countries rich and what makes
countries poor and then given I only
have 30 seconds what happened then we
said I realized that there's this new
growing green religion uh which talks
about human beings as being you know
basically a cancer on the planet and I
believe in the exact opposite I think
that the more people we have provided
that they are free so they can exercise
their their minds their thinking can
invest in the market benefit from it
profit from it that actually having more
people in the world is better because we
create more economic growth and more
prosperity for everyone
that's interesting you're saying that so
I know I said 30 seconds I want you to
feel more comfortable going because it
is a long form podcast but you know so
for me being where I grew up and where
I'm at now it's very important for us to
know you know like it was always wanting
to find out how does one become rich can
everybody become rich what are the
principles that help somebody become
rich so for you coming from the check
background when I lived in Germany there
was a lot of folks from Czechoslovakia
in 89 that were escaping you know a
family that was very close to me the
staff family Yan and Katarina the
specifically family that I remember you
know and they would tell me stories
about what it was like there so for you
what does it what what conditions and
climate helps people become rich and the
same as help some people become poor
well uh
everybody not everybody can become
wealthy know everybody can become
successful
um you know you can only work with
whatever god-given talents uh Slash DNA
you have but the first prerequisite for
having at least a shot at being
successful and Rich that is you have to
live in a country uh where uh you have
basically the freedom of both political
and economic freedom uh what do I mean
by political or well freedom of speech
for example is incredibly important uh
to be able to interact with people like
you exchanging ideas learning from each
other
um maybe innovating something together
then applying those ideas in the
marketplace and if it works then of
course profiting now that only works
under some form of a free market system
if you are in North Korea it doesn't
really matter what great ideas you have
you cannot Implement them first you
cannot vocalize them because you have a
a complete ban on Free Speech but also
you cannot really Implement them in
practice there is no Market where you
can succeed with your ideas or your your
Innovations so I would say a free market
over time has proven to be the the best
way in order to generate economic growth
and it's not just capitalism in the way
that we understand it over the last 300
years but even if you look at the past
it's it's its localities that have
allowed for greater openness uh where
the government took its boot off the
necks of ordinary people where where uh
where people were able to flourish and
become rich that includes song China in
12th Century A.D an incredibly
sophisticated and Wealthy societies and
then when the Ming come in basically
they have 800 years of stagnation simply
because the government changes and they
change the political and economic ideas
institutions that they have uh similarly
in uh you know say for example in in
ancient Rome second century a very high
high level of of stability which then
gets replaced by obviously the collapse
of the Roman Empire in Dark Ages so you
can have these fluorescences of of
economic growth but they usually they
usually Peter out because politics
change and whatever and my big concern
about the United States right now is
that I would like us not to be one of
those uh one of those countries where we
have a sort of a 200 year period of high
economic growth and then suddenly
everything stops and we have stagnation
for the next 500 years if you believe
the future looks bright order your
future looks bright hat today
thank you